je funèbres aux accents politique
empreinte de tristesse mais également
d'espoir famille responsables religieux
politiques et célébrités étaient
rassemblés hier à minneapolis pour
honorer la mémoire de georges flotte
dont la mort sous le genou d'un policier
le 25 mai dernier a déclenché une vague
de colère à travers les états unis
un hommage poignant avec la promesse de
continuer le combat
clément hospital
c'est un silence de huit minutes et 46
secondes qui a marqué l'hommage public à
la mémoire de georges floyd temps
pendant lequel le policier derek chauvin
est resté agenouillé sur le coût de cet
homme de 40 ans malgré ses supplications
famille responsables religieux hommes
politiques encore célébrités étaient
rassemblées pour honorer sa mémoire
présent lors de la cérémonie la figure
du mouvement de défense des droits
civiques le révérend al sharpton a
prononcé une oraison revendicatrice
réclamant une réforme du système de
justice américain ce qui est arrivé à
jake lloyd se produit tous les jours
dans ce pays
dans l'éducation les services de la
santé et dans tous les domaines de la
vie américaine
il est temps pour nous de nous mobiliser
au nom de georges et de leur dire
ôtez vos genoux de nos coûts ôtez vos
genoux de nos coûts une formule martelé
à plusieurs reprises
invoquant le genou du policier derek
chauvin mais surtout le genou de
l'amérique métaphore de plusieurs
siècles d'oppression de la communauté
afro américaine
une formule qui a résonné jusque dans
l'enceinte du capitole où les sénateurs
démocrates ont eu poser genou à terre
nous sommes venus aujourd'hui au
seigneur par solidarité avec les
courageux américain qui manifestent
pacifiquement contre les injustices
raciales à travers notre nation nous
sommes venus aujourd'hui reconnaître que
ou qu'elle soit l'injustice est une
menace pour la justice partout au même
moment devant le mémorial improvisé à
l'endroit où georges floyd a été tué
la colère a laissé place à l'émotion
c'était triste parce que et si ça avait
été mon père mon père a à peu près le
même âge et si ça avait été mon frère
donc ça m'a vraiment affecté
c'est un homme afro-américains il fait
partie de ma communauté la paix n'a pas
encore été rétabli parce qu'il n'y a
toujours pas de justice
ce qu'ils y ont fait douloureux de
prendre sa vie comme ça d'avoir écrasé
son coup avec le genou c'est vraiment
bien de voir tout le monde veut venir
ici tellement de gens différents sont
venus ici apporter leur soutien donné de
leur temps et leurs ressources et
apportent leur soutien à tout le monde
je pense que c'est vraiment fantastique
partout dans le pays les manifestations
se sont poursuivies au 11e jour de
mobilisation
la situation commence à s'apaiser après
plus d'une semaine de débordements